KAVANAUGH, A MAN WITH IMPECCABLE
SERVICE AND A 40 YEAR TRACK
RECORD, THEY CAN TAKE DOWN
ANYBODY.
ANY CONSERVATIVE, ANY POLITICIAN
FOR ANY REASON ON ANY ALLEGATION
WITH ZERO PROOF, EVER.
THE SENATE CANNOT LET THIS
HAPPEN.
THEY CANNOT REWARD THIS
BEHAVIOR.
JOINING US NOW, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU,
THANK YOU.
I'VE KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
>> 20 YEARS.
>> Sean: AS IT WAS HAPPENING
OF HIS LIFE ON MY RADIO SHOW AND
ON MY NEXT BREAK, I DON'T THINK
YOU EVER HAD A MORE POWERFUL
MOMENT IN YOUR CAREER.
>> Senator Graham: I JUST TOLD
THE TRUTH.
IT'S NOT ABOUT FINDING THE TRUTH
BETWEEN DR. FORD AND BRETT
KAVANAUGH, IS ABOUT DELAYING THE
HEARING TO GET PAST THE
MIDTERMS, I HOPE THEY PICK UP
THE SENATE AND DENYING THE SEAT
TO BE FILLED BY DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE FBI, AND IF
YOU REALLY WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
THE FBI THOUGHT ABOUT THIS, YOU
WOULD COME FORWARD WHEN HE FIRST
KNEW ABOUT IT.
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT
PROTECTING DR. FORD.
THE ONE THING I LEARNED BEYOND
ANY DOUBT TODAY, ANY DOUBT, IS
YOU NEVER INTENDED TO PROTECT
DR. FORD.
EVERYTHING I BELIEVED I KNEW
ABOUT BRETT KAVANAUGH, I AM MORE
CONVINCED THAN EVER THAT HE
DIDN'T DO IT.
HE IS THE RIGHT GUY TO BE ON THE
COURT.
MS. FORD HAS A PROBLEM AND
DESTROYING JUDGE KAVANAUGH'S
LIFE WON'T FIX HER PROBLEM.
AND IF WE LEGITIMIZE THIS, GOD
HELP US ALL BECAUSE BOTH SIDES
CAN DO THIS TO MY FRIENDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
I WOULD NEVER HAVE DONE THIS TO
ONE OF YOUR NOMINEES.
YOU VOTED FOR PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW -- >> Sean: YOU SHARED
YOUR JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
'S BEFORE IT USED TO BE IF YOU
ARE QUALIFIED, ELECTIONS MATTER.
NOW WHEN WE WIN, OR DONALD TRUMP
WINS, THERE ARE NO RULES OR
BOUNDARIES.
NOT ONLY IS HE THAT INCREDIBLY
QUALIFIED JUDGE, OR AN
INCREDIBLY DECENT MAN, HE AND
HIS WIFE ARE THE PARENTS OF THE
YEAR.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE AN
AWARD FOR PARENTING, I WOULD
GIVE TO ASHLEY AND BRETT BASED
ON WHAT HIS DAUGHTER SAID ABOUT
WHO TO PAY FOR.
SO I'M HONORED TO HELP HIM.
IF I HELPED HIM TODAY, IT'S ONE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF MY CAREER.
AND TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES,
IF THIS GUY GOES DOWN, THEN WE
DON'T DESERVE TO STAY IN POWER,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT POWER TO
ME.
IT IS ABOUT THE PROCESS.
JOE MANCHIN, I LIKED HIM A LOT.
JOE, YOU CAN'T FIGURE THIS OUT,
TRUMP WON BY 40 POINTS.
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT BRETT
KAVANAUGH IS A SERIAL?
DO YOU BELIEVE ANY OF THIS
GARBAGE?
I'M SORRY THAT DR. FORD WENT
THROUGH THIS, SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE
HAD TO GO THROUGH IT BUT I'M
CONVINCED BEYOND ANY SHADOW OF A
DOUBT THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH IS
NOT THE MAN THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO MAKE HIM AND THIS IS ALL
POLITICAL.
SO JOE I HOPE YOU STEP UP.
HEIDI, I HOPE LIKE YOU A LOT.
JOE DONNELLY, GREAT GUY.
WHY CAN'T YOU TALK ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT WE MET THE BURDEN HERE?
IF HE HAD TO PROVE HE WAS
INNOCENT, HE DID IT FOR ME, BUT
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO.
>> Sean: REPUBLICANS MET IN
CONFERENCE TONIGHT AND, BRING US
INSIDE THE MEETING IS MUCH AS
YOU ARE ABLE TO SHARE.
>> I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DOING WHAT HE
DID TODAY?
YOUR LIFE IS RIPPED APART,
YOU'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS FOR
WEEKS AND THEY SPRING IT OUT YOU
OUT ON THE, AND THEN MICHAEL
AVENATTI COMES OUT AND SAYS YOU
ASSAULT WOMEN AND YOUR WHOLE
LIFE IS ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED?
I THINK REPUBLICANS TODAY FELT
LIKE BRETT KAVANAUGH NOT ONLY
MET THE TEST AND PASS THE TEST,
AND I WILL BE BROKENHEARTED.
IF THE SENATE REJECTS THIS GOOD
MAN.
>> Sean: BOB CORKER SAID YES,
JEFF FLAKE OFF-CAMERA SAID THIS
IS A TOUGH ONE.
>> Senator Graham: I WOULD SAY
IT IS TOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
DR. FORD BUT I'VE BEEN A LAWYER
ALL MY LIFE, I USE TO DO THIS
FOR A LIVING.
YOU COULD GET A WARRANT.
SHE CAN'T TELL YOU WHERE IT
HAPPENED OR WHAT HAPPENED, IT'S
NOT HE SAID, SHE SAID, IT'S THEY
SAID AND THEY SAID.
ALL PEOPLE NAMES THAT IT DIDN'T
HAPPENED.
AND YOU CAN'T GET THE DATE OR
THE TIME.
MY GOD, HE WENT THROUGH A
COUNTER OF 1982, THIS IS THE
MOST SQUARED AWAY GUY THAT I'VE
EVER MET MY LIFE.
I WAS HONORED TO BE IN HIS
PRESENCE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A MAN COMMANDED
A ROOM LIKE HE DID, I'VE NEVER
SEEN ANYONE MORE HE IS ABUSE
THAN HE WAS.
>> Sean: I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
QUOTING SUSAN COLLINS BECAUSE
SHE IS THE ONE THAT RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT FROM THE BEGINNING,
THIS HAS BEEN UNFAIR TO BOTH
SIDES HERE.
AND SHE'S BEEN RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
>> Senator Graham: WHAT I
WOULD TELL SUSAN IS, IF YOU ARE
THE WAY THEY SAY BRETT IS, HE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE LIFE BRETT HAS
LIVED.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE 65 WOMEN COMING
FORWARD, WE WOULDN'T HAVE SIX
FBI INVESTIGATIONS THAT FOUND
NOTHING, YOU WOULDN'T BE IN THIS
PROFILE OF A JOB.
HE'S BEEN IN THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT, A TARGET FOR 26
YEARS.
HE FOUND OUT ABOUT IT AFTER THE
HEARING WAS OVER, THEY KNEW
ABOUT IT AND THEY SAT ON IT,
THERE IS NO CORROBORATION.
AND THE MICHAEL AVENATTI THING
TELLS YOU WHERE THEY ARE HEADED
WITH HIM.
IF THEY DELAY THIS, THERE WILL
BE MORE COMING AND HE DOESN'T
DESERVE THAT.
IT'S TIME TO VOTE.
>> Sean: THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MEETS TOMORROW MORNIN
MORNING.
AND THEN THE FULL SENATE WILL
VOTE WE EXPECT, TUESDAY?
>> Senator Graham: I WILL GO
THROUGH WHY I BELIEVE HE IS
QUALIFIED AND CAPABLE AND I WILL
TELL YOU WHAT I THINK HAS
HAPPENED HERE IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
IF THIS IS THE NEW NORM, GOD
HELP US ALL.
I HOPE JEFF CAN GET THERE.
I WOULD JUST STRESS AGAIN, THIS
MAN HAS LED AN INCREDIBLE LIFE
AND EVERYTHING THEY ARE SAYING
ABOUT HIM IS MADE UP AND IT
COMES OUT OF THE LEFT FIELD.
IT'S NOT CORROBORATED.
PLEASE DON'T TAKE AWAY
EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE.
HE'S NUMBER ONE IN HIS CLASS,
EVER SINCE HE'S DONE ANYTHING.
IF WE GO TO THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE, -- IF YOU LIVE IN THESE
TRUMP STATES, GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE EMOTION OF
TODAY, AND ALL THAT HAPPENED, --
MY BEST FRIEND FROM THIRD GRADE,
HIS NAME IS JOHN GOMEZ AND HE
CALLED ME YESTERDAY.
HE SAID HANNITY, YOU ALWAYS SAY
EVERY 2-4 YEARS, REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST AND SEXIST AND MY WHOLE
LIST AS HE CALLS LATE.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
MORE NOW BECAUSE WHEN YOU SAY
THESE HORRIBLE THINGS, AND NOW
WE HAVE GOTTEN USED TO IT, WE
EXPECT IT, IT'S LIKE MY FATHER
WAS KILLED ALL OVER AGAIN.
CHURCHES WILL BURN OUR     OR CO
ELECT REPUBLICANS AND BLACK
CHURCHES WILL BURN OUR     OR CS
WILL BURN.
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO COUNT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THE CENSUS,
AL GORE SAID.
THIS HAS TO STOP, SENATOR.
>> Senator Graham: THESE ARE
POLITICAL ARGUMENTS THAT WE CAN
HANDLE AND WE DON'T LIKE THAT
BUT THIS IS DESTROYING SOMEBODY.
>> Sean: YES.
>> Senator Graham: I WOULD
HOPE AND PRAY THAT I NEVER GET
THIS DESPERATE AS A POLITICAL
PERSON TO DESTROY SOMEBODY.
THIS WAS A WHOLESALE EFFORT TO
TAKE A GOOD MAN AND RUIN HIS
LIFE AND IT BACKFIRED ON HIM.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICAL
ARGUMENTS, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
WHAT THEY WILL DO OR WE WILL DO,
THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
WERE WILLING TO SET A MAN UP AND
DESTROY HIS LIFE.
>> Sean: IT WAS HARD TO WATCH.
>> Senator Graham: IT WAS HARD
TO WATCH AND WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT HIS DAUGHTER -- LET'S PRAY
FOR THE LADY, TOO.
THIS IS A GOOD MAN, PLEASE VOTE
FOR HIM.
>> Sean: SENATOR I THINK THE
REASON YOUR MOMENT WAS SO
POWERFUL IS IT WAS RAW, REAL AND
UNPLANNED.
>> Senator Graham: IT WAS
TOTALLY REAL.
US BEFORE YOU KNOW WHAT GOT ME
WAS, WHY WON'T YOU AGREE TO THE
FBI INVESTIGATION, WHAT DO YOU
HAVE TO HIDE?
THESE OF THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO DO
AN INVESTIGATION BECAUSE IT
WOULDN'T HELP US.
THEY KNEW IT FOR WEEKS, PLANNED
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AND
INTENTIONALLY, AND I AM
CONVINCED TO COME OUT AT
DR. FORD FOR THE PUTTER, WE SAW
TODAY AND IT BLEW UP IN THEIR
FACE.
AND I HOPE AMERICA UNDERSTANDS
THAT IF THIS IS THE NEW WAY OF
DOING BUSINESS, WE ARE GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION.